hey guys I've recently had another
question from someone that wanted to
know do I have to do wild-caught fish
because it's very expensive couldn't I
just do farm raised fish and the answer
is yes because if you knew what farm
raised fish consumed you would
definitely not consume them because they
have cornmeal which is GMO soy bean okay
meal which is a GMO again canola that's
GMO genetically modified which means it
has residue of glyphosate which is a
herbicide wheat okay animal by-products
meat which is probably fed corn soy and
canola blood of the animal feathers
poultry fat which is again fed GMO
grains fish meat sometimes antibiotics
depending on what part of the country
that the they farmed the fish and on top
of everything there's high levels of
PCBs I put a link down below for more
information it's a very very toxic the
other problem with farm raised fish is
that they contain three times the amount
of omega-6 fatty acids as compared to
wild-caught and omega-6 is very
inflammatory so you could get some more
inflammation in your body and only half
the Omega threes so you have this very
out of balance
unhealthy ratio of six versus three
which is going to set people up for more
inflammation so spend the money invest
in your health as your new health
insurance get the wild-caught don't get
the farm-raised
so if you don't have this book you might
want to check it out it's entitled it's
not lose weight to get healthy it's get
healthy to lose the weight healthy
ketosis and in a minute fasting check it
out I put a link down below